[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ان اهم ما يقوم به الباحث الرصيد
في مجتمعه هو التاريخ لتكون وتشكل وولاده
الافكار والحركات والتيارات في هذا
المجتمع يرضى فهمه ومعرفه ظروف نشاته ثم
التنبؤ واستشراف مستقبله وهذا تحديدا ما
فعله ضيف حلقاتنا الثلاث الباحث والمفكر
والسياسي الكويتيه الدكتور علي زميل والذي
ولد في اسره المحافظه مطلع الخمسينيات في
الكويت اللحظه الفارقه في عمر الدوله
الصغيره والوادعه والمختلفه ايضا حيويه
وفاعليه تفتح اواعي الدكتور مع بدايات
تراجع المشروع القومي في العالم العربي مع
هزيمه 67 رغم مشاعره القوميه الجيش الا
انه وجد في الحركه الاسلاميه امتدادا ما
نشا عليه في الاسره المحافظه وكان قد طلب
العلم في المساجد على يد عدد من المشائخ
من بينهم الشيخ عبد الرحمن عبد الخالق
لانضم مبكرا بعد ذلك الى حركه الاخوان
المسلمين عبر مؤسستها المتمثله بجمعيه
الاصلاح الاجتماعيه في الكويت وما انت
تخرج من الجامعه في نهايه السبعينيات حتى
التحق بوزاره الاوقاف والشؤون الاسلاميه
الجهاز الحكومي الذي عمل به منذ تخرجه حتى
تبوا اعلى منصب فيه بعد تعيينه وزير
للاوقاف عام
1994 محدثا نقله النوعيه في اليات وتوجهات
الوزاره في عده مناحي وكان جميع قد قرر
منتصف الثمانينات استكمال دراسته العليا
وهو وكيل للوزاره في مفارقه لازمت الرجل
بانحيازه الدائم للعلم والتغيير والتجديد
كما فعل لاحقا يوم كتب المقالات النقديه
الداعيه للتجديد من على سده الوزاره ولان
العلم والفكر يحث دائما على النقد
والتجديد والتطوير لم يسعى الرجل صندوق
التنظيم فقرر ان يترك جماعه الاخوان نهايه
الثمانينات دون ان تتاثر مرجعته الاسلاميه
وكان قد انتقل من معسكر السياسه الى عالم
الفكري والثقافه يؤرخ الرجل في عمله
البارز الحركات الاسلاميه في الكويت من
عام 1950 حتى عام 2019 لنشاه الكويت
الحديثه والتفاعل الذي حدث في مكونات
المجتمع والتميز بين مرحله التاسيس
والنشاه التي اتسمت بالبساطه والوضوح في
شكل المجتمع الى مرحله الدوله الحديثه
والتفاعلات التي نتجت عنها المفكر الكويتي
الدكتور علي سبيع ضيف المقابله في هذه
الحلقه والحلقات التي تليها وسيره ذاتيه
يمكن معها ان نكتشف الكثير عن ملامح
الدوله والمجتمع في الكويت فعلا ومرحبا
بكم
[موسيقى]
في اي اسره في البيئه في اي ظرف ولد
اسره كويتيه تقليديه
مطابقه للمتوسطه اذا جاهزنا نتكلم عنها في
حقبه الستينات ما قبل الستينات اعتقد
تصنيف المتوسطه كان يعني ده بيكون يعني
من حي المرقاب وهو حي يعني قد يكون يتميز
انه اغلبيه كويتيه نجديه ذوي الاصول
النجديه اسرتك من اصول جديد
[موسيقى]
يعني بالديني والاجتماعي وحتى احيانا في
المنهج التفكير كان حاله المحافظه يعني
المجتمع بشكل عام يعني على قدر بالمحافظه
لكن المحافظه النجديه ربما تكون فيها تميز
نوعا ما هي المدرسه مختلفه يعني لما تاتي
الى مثلا اهل جبله وشارك كانوا يتميزون
باكثر انفتاحا ومرونه حقيقه في الجانب
الاجتماعي او الفكري يوديني كون هم قضيه
همم الانفتاح
الاسبقيه التاريخيه الزمنيه همم الثقافه
ليست ثقافه
ضيقه كما هي في الكويتيين ذو الاصول
النجديه او ذوي الهجره الاحدث من من سبق
كيف تصف المجتمع الكويتي في فتره خلينا
نقول ستينات خاصه مع نشاه الدستور استقلال
الكويت بدء الحركه خلينا نقول البرلمان
نشات البرلمان بشكل يعني بشكل واضح
الديمقراطيه الكويتيه التي تميزت على
المحيط كيف كشاف صغير انت في التعليق نقول
في منتصف الستيني
احدث حاله غريبه في التركيب السكانيه وفي
ثقافه القطاعات يعني انا اخذني اضرب لك
مثال
منقاد عمليه
خلينا نقول المشاركه الشعبيه و
الديمقراطيه منذ العشرينات لغايه وضع
الدستور 62 كانت بشكل رئيسي هي الطبقه
المرجوازيه الوطنيه
التاريخيه التي كانت لها تفاعل في المجتمع
بشكل كبير فيجب ان نكون صادقين كانوا
يمثلون
الضمير السياسي في الحياه في المطالبه
بالمشاركه الشعبيه
السلطه هو لها ابعد يعني حتى لا نكون
مثاليين يعني لانه كان يملكون او كانوا
يقومون بادوار اقتصاديه رئيسيه وماليه
تدعم الدوله
الوحيدين الذين يدفعون الضرائب من خلال
الجمارك وغيرها
وكانت هذه الرسوم تنفق
تذهب الى خزانه الدوله فتنفق على التعليم
والصحه والمجالس الاوقاف والمجالس التعليم
وغيرك وبالتالي كان لديهم شعور لان نحن
مشاركين اساسا في الانفاق كما هو الان
النظريه الديمقراطيه
تضيف لها العمق التاريخي لمعظمهم
كانت الحقيقه حاله متميزه في انهم كانوا
احدى مراكز القوه الرئيسيه التي تبنوا
قضيه الديمقراطيه او المشاركه في ال 20 ثم
في 38 ثم لا تجيب 38 برومو موزه هو من قال
المجلس التاسيسي برمودا احد حتى 62
فمؤكد هذا الجاني يسجل يعني
ابعاده بقضي النظر عن تبرير النيات هل هي
قضيه وطنيه بحثه
وهنا فعلا تختلط الامور ولكن لا يمكن في
تاريخ الكويت انا نقفل هذا الدور لاهميه
المستقبليه في انه هذه الطبقه يجب الان في
صراع داخل الطبقه وعلى فكره لما قلت طبقه
الوطنيه يجب ان نكون امناء سبقتها الطبقه
البرجوازيه الدينيه قبل العشرين انا كنت
بسال هذا السؤال دكتور هل هي ذات بعد
محافظه
في في اسماء مسيره المجتمع
في اوائل القرن في عهد الشيخ مبارك
البرجوازيه
الكويتيه كانت مرجوازيه ذات ميول دينيه
وبالتالي نجد ان من انشا المدرسه
المباركيه ثم اول مستوصف في الكويت كمنافس
للمستشفى الارساليه الامريكيه كانوا من
رجالات الكويت ومن تجاره الكويت ذوي
الميول الدينيه لكن في الثلاثينات نلاحظ
تحولها مع البعد العروبي القومي يعني لو
نعيد التاريخ راح نجد انه كان في عهد
الشيخ مبارك الصراع العثماني الانجليزي
يعني كان في بعد ديني خارج الكويت اكثر
لما ناتي للثلاثينات راح يجب ان نلاحظ ان
البعد العروبي القومي كان هو الذي يملا
الساحر وخصوصا جارتنا العراق فحدث تحول في
هذه الطبقه احسنت بعض رموزه وخصوصا الكثير
منهم
اعمال في العراق
او حته بعضهم درسوا بالعراق
فهذا قضيه مهم الكويت دوله امتداد وليست
مركز نعترف يعني
للجذور في السعوديه في العراق
فهي تتاثر بالمراكز
السعوديه ممكن نقول المركز الحركه
الوهابيه مركز ذلك الوقت لم تكن دوله
مركزيه سياسيه لكن من المؤكد ان السعوديه
كدوله او مجتمع كانت دوله مركزيه في
الجانب الفكري في العراق مركز العراق مركز
فكري من ناحيه
الثقافيه العروبيه ومركز فكري وثقافي شيعي
كون المرجعيه الحوزه العلميه في العراق
كان الحوزات التي تمثل العالم
العالم
يتاثرون بما يجري في العراق القوميين
يتاثرون
الكويتيين السنه يتاثرون بالمرجعيه
الوهابيه في اوائل القرن كانت تاثر في فكر
عصر مدرسه النهضه كانت تاثر محمد عبده
رشيد رضا
محب الدين الخطيب هذه الكتله الثقافيه
الاسلاميه التي استمر تاثيرها لليوم فلما
نتكلم عن برجوازيه الكويتيه يتكلم كويتيه
الوطنيه بشقها القومي وبشقها الديني
الكويت دوله مركز دوله صغيره
لماذا تبدو الكويت مختلفه بشكل لافتات
ومميز سياسيا اجتماعيا وحتى الى درجه
كبيره اقتصاديا الى فتره طويله عن دول
المركز المحيطه انا اعتقد المركز هو من
يتبنى مشهوره
مشروع الكويت تاريخيا كونها ميناء وعلى
الساحر
وارتباط اهلها بالتجاره الخارجيه خاصه
وطبيحه تشكل الدوله في شكلها الجديد اللي
هو مع هجره العتوم وعلى الصباح
ليس له جذور واضحه في قضيه العصبيه لتوجه
لفكر لماذا لقبيله مجموعه مهاجره
في الكويت
يعني
هجره الكويت
معظمها كان لاشباب اقتصاديه يعني من يترك
العراق او برر فارس
الشريحه او الكتله الكويتيه الشيعيه جوز
كبير منها مكان لهذا السبب كان بحث عن
الحريه المذهبيه
سياسيه تاريخيه احيطت في مناطق مثل الحساء
ادت الى هذه الهجره
المركزيه للهجره كانت الحريه الحريه
التسامح المذهبي التسامح الثقافي كانت بلد
مفتوحه دائما الدول الحديثه
في التشكيل تكون اكثر نموا من الدول ذات
التراث الحضاري يعني دائما يضرب المثال
هذا لماذا امريكا الدوله الناشئه اكثر دول
العالم تقدما ونموذ لانها حديثا لانها
بينما الدوله
هي اعرق الحضارات الانسانيه لماذا متخلفه
قياس الحراره
مما قيدها عن النظره المستقبل
جزء من حياتك هاي القضيه مهمه مهمه
للناس بس في ناس اسلاميين وفي ناس عاديين
لا يعني نشاه كان نادر ما تجد عندنا في
عمرنا في ذلك الوقت
همم الخروج على المالوف فكان
لقايه سن معين في النشاه انت
يتشكل ترتيب الذهنيه
والفكريه والشخصيه
في مرحله معينه يبدا هنا الخيارات اما
تكمل على نفس الخالق
بتقليدته
اجتماعيه او ان انت تتشكل الاخر انا من
حسن حظي يعني يمكن ان في تلك الحقبه
واثناء الدراسه المتوسطه والثانويه
استطعت اني التقي به فئات عربيه متعدده
وبالاخص من الزملاء من اليمن
وبالاخص من اليمن الجنوبي ذو الفكر
وهذا فكره يعني بالنسبه لنا جديد ومثير
مثير يعني ويشبه طبيعه بحره
النسبه لك يعني حتى المصطلح
اييي
الافكار
معانا الزملاء الفلسطينيين في الماده في
المدارس
النشيطين منهم المدرسين ايضا فهذا الجو
طبيعي اذا تكون ست تاثيرات امور كثيره
يعني ابتدات من الفريج من الحي من المسجد
من المدرسه تيارات العروبيه والقوميه الى
اللقاءات همم
تاثيرات همم الحقيقه احداث العربيه يعني
انا التي كانت ايضا بشكل موازي
مثل اي شاب يعني تبدا ببيئه محافظه الى ما
تحدث خدمه انك تكتشف اقوى عالم موازي
كالعالم الناصري القومي العروبي او البعث
او غيره تبدا تحاول استكشاف المحيطات
الدكتور الطبيعي انك تكون قومي او يساري
الطبيعي في تلك الفتره مع موجه القوميه
والماده الثوري
والخطاب الناصري اللي قالها بالوجدان واثر
حتى في انظمه
ثانيه
كان طبيعي ولا كان في نوع من التحدي لا هو
انا بدات بشكل حيادي ان الاسلامي والعروبي
واحد واحد واحد
طيب هنا اقوى مفارقه لطيفه
[موسيقى]
النكته يعني يعني الذي ابعدني عن الخط
العروبي لم يكن لم يكن الديني
لما كنت لما كنت اجلس بحوارات
فكان طبيعي
لان الاسلاميين متراجعين
كبير جدا
الثوره المصريه في سراجه
فعاله تتكلم عن حقبه الستينات بالنسبه لي
كانوا الاخوان مضروبين وهم الفصيله الوحيد
اللي على الساحه ومظلوم يعني
التدين الشخصي هذا التدين تعبدي سلوكي ليس
فكري
فلما تلتقي بمجاميع يساريه واحنا ما تتكلم
عن الكويت الظاهره مر فيها بالوطن العربي
كل العرب هذا هل من سوء حظي من حسن حظي لا
كانت القضيه اللي يسار نظرتها الى القوميه
هناك قضيه مهمه احنا جيلنا كان جيل الفكر
الاممي على مستوى العالم
شيوعيه راس ماليه القوميه حتى القوميه
اماميه عابره للاوطان واحد احيانا القارات
يعني والاسلاميه
عابراليه الماركسيه واهله
فانا الحقيقه
لا يمكنك ان تقبل الفكر
لكن الحقيقه كنت احترم المنهج العقلي
ولما كنت اقرا في المؤلفات الماركسيه
كنت استخدمها ادوات هذه النظريه العقده
ادواتها في مجله اخرى
بعدين اكتشفت ان شرعيه افلا يتفكرون افلا
يعقلون
هي انت مطالب انك تفكر وليس ان تتلقاها
ويتفكرون ذات معنى عقلي
هلا يتذكرون وبالتالي الذي ابعدني ثم جاءت
هزيمه 67
[موسيقى]
القرن العشرون حتى عصفت رياح القوميه
العربيه بكل ما عداها وشاع فكرها بين شعوب
المنف المنطقه مدفوعا بالروح التي بثها
وصول جمال عبد الناصر الى سده الحكم في
مصر لكن الامر لم يستغرق اكثر من 15 عاما
ليتلقى المشروع القومي ضربه قاسمه في
يونيو حزيران من عام 67 عندما انهزمت
الجيوش العربيه امام القوات الاسرائيليه
التي احتلت الضفه الغربيه وسينا والجولان
دفعه واحده
وعلى انقاذ الفكره القوميه التي اخذت
تنحصر شيئا فشيئا بدات التيارات الاسلاميه
تحاول سد الفرغب مستغله الفشل والاخفاقات
للمشروع العربي في ميادين السياسه
والعسكره والاقتصاد والتنميه وعلى راس تلك
التيارات جاءت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
التي تاسست قبل نحو قرن مشكله باكوره
الحركات الاسلاميه في المنطقه
توال بعد ذلك تاسيس عدد من الحركات ذات
المرجعيه الاسلاميه ومع بلوغها ذروه
نشاطها منتصف السبعينات رفعت شعارات كبيره
تحاكي الى حد من بعيد ما رسمه المعسكر
القومي المهزوم لكن عابها انها بقيه هي
الاخرى مجرده حبر على ورق
كثيره هي الاختلافات بين المشروعين او
الفكرين غير ان القاسم المشتركه بينهما
كان الفشل في تقبل الاخر والاخفاق في
انتاج مؤسسات او انظمه قادره على اداره
شؤون الحكم دون سذاجه مفرطه او دكتاتوريه
متجبره متى اصبحت بشكل واضح جزءا من
التيار الاسلامي الممثل بالاخوان المسلمين
في مرحله الثانويه الثانويه
يعني لا يتفكرون ما كنت تطبقها على
الافكار اللي كانت رايحه الاسلاميه في تلك
الفتره واللي الاخرين ايضا يطرحون اتجاه
الاسلاميين لانه لاحقا بدا
همم التوجه النقدي عند علي صبيح
في تلك الحقبه كان الاسلاميين مضطهدين
امنيا وسياسيا وفكريا
ودائما الشباب يبحث عن المظلوميه وينكم
فيحاول ان يكون مع المظلوميه فكانوا يعني
من الامور وانا بالثانويه كنت باطار
الاخوان التي استثارتني جدا يمكن تنجب
السياق العام انها حدثت ندوه في جامعه
الكويت
اقامه الاتحاد الوطني في ذلك الوقت هو كان
القياده المركزيه في لجنه التنفيذ اليسار
الطلابي قبل 78 لما كانت الاحتلال فيها
المسلمين واستمر
لكن والقياده المحليه اللي هو فرع الكويت
كان القومي
املون
ما في تمثيل لهم حول الاختلاط في ذلك
الوقت
خرجت مجله الاتحاد
بصوره ماخوذه فيها وجوه الاسلاميين وهم
يقطعون الافطاط بشكل
فبذلك الوقت ما كانت تفكير في قضيه
الابداع والتطور اثنين كانوا الاخوان في
ذلك الوقت
يدورون السلامه يعني
مو وقت انه ما دخله مجالات كثيره علشان
تستطيع تقيمهم لم يكنون
لا يملك لا يملكوا برامج لان لا يملكون
القدره انه يدخلوا في بعض مش مرحله نقديه
ان هذا هويتنا الاسلام في همم مصادر القوه
في الثلاث جمعيه الاصلاح ذلك الوقت نعم
لكن
السيسيت على جمعيه الارشاد
في اوائل الستينات في ام سده في بيت داخل
المحدود استاجره
كانت ما ياتوا كل يومين ثلاثه الا مكتوبه
على البوابه او ترمى بعض القناني مالت
الخمر اعرب ان كان في حاله
فكانوا مجرد يعني يلا يلموا بعض في ذلك
الوقت انك تلقى مسجد في شاب يصلي
الفجر
احنا يجب ان نقرا التاريخ في عصره لما
نقول لماذا لم تنتقد ما كانوا قد مشيع
عشان ينتقد
الان انضميت فيها المرحله الثانويه
وتخرجت من الجامعه درست الحقوق حقوق حقوق
شريعه
دائما نجد هذا البعدين
وفكر شخص دكتور
78 عملت وزاره الاوقاف لانه الوزاره
مرتبطين فيها في الحديث انك اصبحت وزير
لها
عملت في الوزاره
78 79 تقريبا
كان الائتلافيه وتشكيل الائتلافيه
للاسف عم يتخرجت
مرني
يوم السبت
رئيس جمعيه الاصلاح
جمعيه الاخوان المسلمين
بعد ما تم يعني او بعد ما تسكرت الشعت في
ال 63 اسسه جمعيه الصراحه
ببعض اعيان الكويت اهل الكويت جزء منهم
كان على ارتباط تاريخي بالارشاد بعض منهم
قليل جدا من الاخوان لان اعداد الاخوان في
ذلك الوقت
لكن الاغلبيه عيان
الفكر القومي والاشتراك
والتحرر يستفز بعض
وقعت الفورد قال لك انت متدينين وتكلمون
عن كذا هذه فرصه
واستمريت الى انجلت البعثه في في بريطانيا
لا لا دخلنا هنا لما دخلنا الاوقاف
دخلنا بسرعه من نوع ثاني
بدايه الامر ايه هالمره الصراع مع
اللي حواليك من الاسلاميه
كل سنه كانت الوزاره تقليديه اساسا الشباب
الاسلامي في ذلك الوقت
هتدخل وزاره تقليديه يعني اذكر اول يعني
لقاء شويه في
مضادها يعقوب احمد الله عليه ناداني سلمني
الوعي الاسلامي عندهم ملحق اسمه براعم
الايمان
كلها مكتوب
تطلع معنا
مين دخلنا في مازق
التفكير والتحدي من جديد انت تدير وزاره
في بعض الدول العربيه الان تعتبرها
دستوريا من وزاره السياده لن تعطي البعد
الشرعيه
تمثل القائمه على دين الدوله
ميدان في برامج
للاسف لما تمتع بالعمل الان يوسف الحجي
لانه تغيرت الوزاره جانا وزير
من الوزراء القلائق ذو التميز الفكري في
ذلك الوقت الاخ احمد الجعفر
كان وكيل الوزاره مساعد في التربيه
قضيه قضيه تفكير
اتفكر جاء على هواك
فانفتحت البدايه بمشاريع الزكاه الاوقاف
العمل الاسلامي الخيري الخارجي
حق الافتاء
والثقافه الاسلاميه
في مناخ عمل اسلامي مجتمعي طاقي
بدا يهيمن على الساحه بدا يستولي على
المساجد
اصبحت مساجد كل المساجد فيها لجان خيريه
او لجان زكاه هي اللي في النهايه
عمل ثقافي بدعم الدوله دكتور
شباب
الدول
بصراحه
اسلاميه طبيعي طبيعي
تليفون
محاضرات مكتبه كل مسجد
تطور الى ان احتكاك مع اداره المسجد مثل
مع الامام الفقير المسكين اللي لا عنده
وزاره توجهه ولا شيء صار احتكاك تنافس بين
التيارات
الاسلاميه
على المساجد
ان يكون هناك مشروع تحدي
فاكتشفنا الاول ان انت عشان تموت تنافس
انت كيان مستقل
حياديه الجهاز
ان تكون الوزاره
لا يملك انسان ولا مذهب ولا طائفه المشروع
الديني مشروع الجهاز
الى الفكره السياسيه في الاسلام الحكومه
والدوله هي جهاز العقيده وكفر ودين
للناس افضل سبل للتعبد والتعلم الديني في
حدود المسجد
طيب
امام ناس تملك رؤى ومشاريع المشروع
الاخواني المشروع السلفي مشاريع متكامله
ومتقدمه جدا على الوزاره التي لا تملك
طبعا هذا وين حنا عندكم موقعين عندك
الثقافه وعندك الافتاء الافتاء رزقنا بشخص
يجب ان يسجل الموقف كان في الاخ الشيخ
مشعل مبارك عبدالله الاحمد مدير اداره
الافتاء وهو من الاسره
الاحمد الصباح
والله يكرمه هذا الرجل كان يرفض المناصب
يرفض كل شيء كان عاشق ويتعبد فيها القضيه
مساله الافتاء واداره الافتاء والاجتهاد
ويعطيه حصانه ويحميها احيانا من السلطه
احيانا وكان له من الهيبه والوقار انه
يعطي هذا
خلق مؤسسه افتاء مستقله انا اتامل يذكر
الاسماء لاعطاء الناس
جينا في المشروع الثقافي
انت دوله مشروع ديني عندك انك
تنشا البلاط فورم المحطه التي الناس تتعبد
عليها في الاطار العام للدوله ولا تنافس
ولا يكون لك مشروع ديني الا من خلال
المبادئ العامه في
لكن عندك خطر انت مسؤول عن توجيه هذه
التيارات زين هم احرار لكن الراي العام
الاسلامي اللي في البلد
اذا تركته راح يعيش حاله تمزق
فانشانا اداره ثقافيه وبدانا بندوى شهيره
الى الان تستمر لكن بمضامين احيانا تصل
الى التناقض سوينا ندوه سنويه وفيها ورش
عمل خلال السنه وهي نجوى الشبه صارت عربيه
واسلاميه اللي هي مستجدات الفكر الاسلامي
والمستقبل ما هي المستجدات وما هو
المستقبل وما هو المستقبل دكتور في هذه
الفتره انت كنت تعبر
رؤيه نقديه اتجاه الوزاره وانت ابن
الوزاره اصبحت مسؤول فيها وانت ايضا ابن
الاخوان المسلمين ابن الحركه هذه تعبر
بشكل اكبر عن عن توجهاتك فكرك ما يعني
يؤمن به او يتمنى لكم مسلمين شوف هذه
ضرتني
انا الحقيقه لا استطيع ان اكون الا محايده
للاخوان بس موضوع الا موضوعي لكن استشهد
انهم اصحاب رؤيه واصحاب فقط لكن في
الوزاره لا
ارتكيت ان لصالحهم
انه يجلسون مع الاخرين بشكل متساوي
ويناقشون
ما عندي مشكله
كل الزملاء رموز الكويت الليبراليين
من سيده فاطمه حسين دكتور الرميحي الجميع
جلسوا على المنصه في هذا اللقاءات
وتحدثوا فيها بيضه
وفي ذلك الوقت من الصحوه والثوره
الايرانيه في فتره الان بدات
كنا ندعو من الحوزه العلميه من ياتي من
ايران ولا من غيره
لاول مره وزاره الاوقاف
تقدم فيها اوراق ورؤى من مشايخ من المذهب
اصبحت فعلا محايده بحد المراه او جهاز
محايد تحاول تحاول بدات فكره
شيعه لم تعد دينيه مغلقه والمفاجاه
ان تاثيرها كبير يعني العالم بعد ثلاث
تاريخ تشوف بعض الرموز تحوله من فكر لفكر
من محافظه الى موضوع عقلاني وكان هدف منها
ان جلسه قبله والتعدديه
هذا في غايه الاهميه
الدكتوره انت رحت وانت في اوجع ملك
الحكومي في منصب وكيل وزاره في وكيل وزاره
هي كانت اجمل شخصيه
84 تقريبا
حدث انتخابات ال 85
في صار في جدل على فلسفه الامل السياسي
والانتخابي
وشعره النجمه
قد يكون فيه اصطدام في الرؤى في ذلك الوقت
بيني وبين الاخرين اللي على الساحه
الاسلاميه
اضافه الى تراكمات الوزاره
يعني الوزاره انت تتعامل مع الاخوان مع
السلف بفصائل لهم
حزب الدعوه
مجموعات الشيخ الشيرازي
يعني انت الكتله تعمل عليك ضغط
ومن هنا ثقافي وكل من يريدك شنو صعوبه
دوره
وفي الدوره قررت اني اجي واقدم دكتوراه
لان اردت احدد موقف من القضيه الدينيه
كلها هذا حسيت انه اخو تجربه
مو بساطه انك تسويها بالقرار الاداري
يعني شوف انت مازلت مثالياتك شلون يعني
انك بتقرر
تبعد فلان تقرب هذا تستشعر احيانا الروحيه
الذنب
منو انت صحيحكم مجموعه شباب
من المساجد كلها اخرجنا منها
الاسلاميه ما ظلمناهم قدمنا لهم في
المساجد اكو بيوت الائمه شقق
اللي انت في داخل المسجد معطيه شقه كامله
نعطيه شقه بس اطلع من المسجد المسجد
للعباده هذا عمل خيري نحترمك عمل تثقيفي
نحترمك اطلع
من بعد الغرفه كاني استشهد دكتور المحادث
عليك ضغط حتى من الاخوان المسلمين اللي
ادى لتركك الاخوان في 88 كانه متعرف
الاخوان لسه توهم مشاركين 81 و85 فالطلبات
يمكن زاهدته الضغط والتيارات الاخرى والله
صدق يكون هذا دفعك الى الاستقاله حتى اكون
همم
لم يكن هناك طلبات كانت هناك من الجميع
حاله في البدايه من الضيق والى ما شاء
الله
فلان يقيمنا لما الدكتور عماره فهمي هويدي
الدكتور العوه دكتور كمال ابو المجد اللي
هم امتداد مدرسه عصر النهضه
دخلت منطقه التنوير الاسلاميه
يعني انا اخذت خمس سنوات في بريطانيا من
غير عائلتي مع انك انت ابو اولاد وكل شيء
عندهم مشكله
لكن حقائق الحق هم بعيدين ان مهتمام نتيجه
ثقل تاريخي ومعارك مستمره وخاصه المظلوميه
عند الاسلاميه السنه والشيعه
اخواننا الشيعه المظلوميه عاد لها جذور
جماعتنا مظلومتهم باستمراريه بجانب القمعي
والسياسي والامني
وغيرها المظلومتك ابدا انتقل الى قضيه
اخرى وهي
قدموا الوزاره مشروع الوزاره
التنويري بان تسمح للجميع البعض بس ما
قدمنا حنا ورقه نقول المعتقد ولا الفوق
الفولاي هذي سمعوا بعض وبس يعني انا اذكر
واحد من المتحاورين
غلط على مجموعه طلع مصور تلفزيون الكويت
المؤتمر الرسمي يسجلها هذا الشاب من هذه
المجموعه هدى الكاميرا قال نفسي
الوسط وعلى الطرف حتى لو اطلع
شفته كان مسكه ورد قلت له احنا الاخر
كان احد من جماعته موجود
شو اللي صار الاخوان كانوا مضايقين
الثلاثه مضايقين اخواننا بعض الشيعه في
قضايا النحاولنا نقول نقدم خدمات المساج
قالوا كثر خيركم للدخلون
شركات النظافه بس عشان نشعر المواطنه
قالوا لكنها وفرتوا علم الميزانيه
الاخوان مشكلتي وياهم مو بس هذه ما كانت
نتيجه
الاخوان في ذلك الوقت
تورطه في ان هم مثل الثالث وصلوا الى
مرحله نضج جماهيري
وحراك طغى سياسيا واجتماعيا على الصحه
كبير
وهزال فكري يعني يعني كانوا املاق
اجتماعيا وسياسيا نقابه الجامعه العالميه
يعني اذا نريد ان نكون مؤدبين ونقول
ضبابيه
في ادبياتهم بالاسم هذا الفتره خرج منها
كثير عبد الله
الشاب سعد البراك كانك كل شخص لديه محاوله
الخروج او التفكير خالص معلش
صندوق لم يستطيع ان يتحمل تنظيم الاخوان
او البقاء داخله هو لو كنت في الاخوان او
غير الاخوان لن تتحمل اذا كنت لك رؤيه
مختلفه اساسا الاخوان
الامانه يعني انا مازلت على علاقه طيبه
لكن هي القضيه
قضيه لما تطرح الجديد والاغلبيه
يريد ان يعيش على التوازن لان هم عندهم
اشكاليه كلها التيارات لماذا يرفضون
الدخول في عمليه الاصلاح والمراجعه لان
عنده توازنات يوميه فهميه الخروج هو امر
ايجابي لانك تصبح حياتي تستطيع ان تقدم
شيء من الفكر شنو احتجاجك انت كنت دكتور
الاحتجاجات اللي اللي خلتتك في المسائل
الفكريه في ما يتعلق بالاخوان التي دفع
الدكتور على الجميع ان يكون لحد اليوم ما
زال قائمه انه تنظيم كبير جدا على الصعيد
الفكري هناك ضبابيه اسمعها من احد الاشخاص
الذين كانوا في الاخوان ومازال يحمل
تقديرا لهذه الجماعه السياسيه والدينيه
يعني اريد ان اقعد دكتور
هالحركات
الحقيقه الا ما نقدر هي دخلت العمل العام
في شعارات اسلاميه سياسيه
وحتى السلفيه التي هي منهج علمي اساسا
دخلت ضمن الفصائل الاسلام السياسي
متاثره في قضيه
الفكر دائما الحركات لتقييمها انظر الفكر
اللحظه التاسيسيه
الاخوان وفصائل الاسلام السياسي بما فيها
السلفيه متاثره جدا بلحظه التاسيس اللي هي
سقوط الخلافه
الخلافه فقط سقوط عاديه يعني معظم
الاساتذه التيارات كانوا رشيد رضا من
السلفيين كان محمد عبده من التنويريين
كانوا ضد الخلافهم وينتقدوا الخلافه لكن
سقوط الخلافه بيد مستعمله
متناقض معك فكريه وحضاريا وسياسيا
ويستعمرك ويريد ان يفرض عليك ثقافه عظمت
قضيه الخلافه وتم تجاوز مفهوم الخلافه
الصحيح انها ليست جزء من الدين
انت وظيفه السياسيه
الامانه مو هذه لا ما بيظلمهم يعني شوف
يعني لا يوجد احد قيم الحركات الاسلاميه
في المنطقه كثف يعني تكون امين لكن هي
استمراريه
هي استمراريه شلون نحطها هي استمراريه
لماذا
انتهى يبقى اسعار الدوله الوطنيه سيئه ثم
دوله وطنيه معقوله اعاده الاسلام كياناتها
والمجتمع مسلم روح اشتغل هو اسير اسير
لحظه لحظه واحده
هذا قادر الثاني اذا انت بتغير تدخل في
مازق اكبر الان التناقض الدوله الحديثه
شرطها عملوا اياها رقم واحد ابي الخلافه
اي خلافه الاماميه مين قال لك اخوه يجب ان
تكون الخلافه اميه واحنا قبل ما تصير 40
سنه على النبوه
عندنا اكثر من الخليفه عبد الله بن الزبير
خلافته في الحجاز
وفي الامويين وين في الشام ثم بعدها لما
خرج سيدنا الحسين
خلافه اخرى على الخلافه بعد 90 سنه سقوط
الخلافه الامويه
قدوم العباسيين في عندنا خلافه الامويه
وين في الاندلس
واجماع العلماء انهم يعطون الشرعيه لكل
هالمؤسسات الان اريد الخلافه الخلافه
اميتها
الدوله الوطنيه
اصحاب الديانات والاثنيات والراي الاخر
طيب اذا هذا يقودك الى قضيه اخرى في
الدوله الحديثه ماذا يملك السياده
مربوطه تطبيق شرع الله كل هالحركات سقطت
الخلافه يجب ان تعود الخلافه لانها تطبيق
شرع الله طبعا مفهوم خاطئ تطبيق شرع الله
مين يقول ان تطبيق شرع الله مناطق بالحكام
او حتى العلماء تطبيق شرع الله مناط في
المجتمع البشر الله عز وجل لما اناب على
الارض انابه من ادم
لمحاكم ولا عالم ولا عالم
بالبشر في المجتمع لان هدف هذا الدين وهذا
الرسالات هي المجتمع انا المجتمع هو الذي
يحمي الشريعه
تطبيق الشريحه
يجب ان تذهب من خلال الحاكم ولا انك تاتي
السلطه من فوق يا اسلامي تاتي للسلطه من
خلال المجتمع المجتمع اذا كان مؤمن بهذا
الدين هو نحن طبق الشريعه اذا له اخر سلوك
من الشريعه الشريعه لا تطب على غير
المسلمين هذه الامور وامور اخرى ادت الى
خروج كل الاخوان بشكل رسمي 88
اطرح لكن طبيعه
وسير يا فاصل جاي يقدم استقالته لا يستقيل
لا يستقيل
انا قدمت استقاله وقلت لهم مع الشكر
ومازلت او دافع عن كل التيارات الاسلاميه
ما فيها الاخوان بنياتها
بمصداقيه شفافيه النيه ولكن الزمن يسبقهم
فما استطيع
اشكرك جزيل الشكر في هذه الحلقه الاولى
ولدينا حلقات اخرى نواصل ونفصل فيها
المشروع والمسيره شكرا وصل لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على طيب المتابعه والقاكم ان شاء
الله الاسبوع المقبل مع الدكتور شكرا
[موسيقى]